hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast switching from manual to
automated mgs library preparation
presented by Tim show mark and mark med
well on application specialist liquid
handling Eppendorf hi I'm Ken Lee Baca
blabbers and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by loggers and sponsored
by Eppendorf for more information on our
sponsor please visit Eppendorf comm now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answerer
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit we have
two presenters for you today dr. Tim
Shaw marks and dr. Markman wall horn dr.
Sean marks works as an application
specialist for automated liquid handling
at the Eppendorf headquarter in Hamburg
Germany
he studied molecular life science in
Germany and Singapore focusing on the
influence of anti-inflammatory
antibodies on allergies to autoimmune
diseases during his master thesis finish
el martes holds a PhD in chemistry
working in the field of biology DeGeorge
Eppendorf in 2016
having a broad background in different
workflows ranging from molecular biology
cell and infection biology to immunology
and biochemistry dr. Han works as an
application specialist for automated
liquid handling at Eppendorf headquarter
in Hamburg Germany mark on roles of PhD
degree in medical sciences before
joining Eppendorf you worked as a
sequencing application specialist at
macro gene incorporated in Amsterdam
welcomed doctors you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much Kaylie for this kind
of reduction so I'm going to start off
this webinar and I will provide the
users perspective to this end of the
story because of my background in
next-generation sequencing but before
doing so I want to start off we're
giving a brief overview I detected
called next-generation sequencing or
abbreviated NGS it's so important to us
all coming to the trend in India as you
can see from this slide
NGS has been tremendously important for
me and I'm sure to a lot of people in
our audience as well this stick
technique has after the introduction in
2008 let's do a tremendous drop in the
cost of per base sequencing as shown
here by the blue line in this chart and
which has even superseded the famous
Moore's Law and semiconductor industry
that means the cost of sequencing is
actually going down even more per year
and it's becoming more and more
affordable another very recent trend
that I have witnessed an industry and
that has made it much more easy for
everybody to sequence their samples is
that of the sequencers are getting
cheaper and cheaper by the year we are
now with to tell in Adrian with this
section of the height the ICG alumina
which only costs around $20,000 it's
much much easier to sequence a sample
and the technology is readily available
this has had a very strong impact on the
publication community out there were
more and more publications in the
science world are relating to the topic
of next-generation sequencing as shown
in the class and most likely this teak
has not been reached yet as this
technology is becoming more and more
readily available with the introduction
of new kits and more easily achievable
but unfortunately I have to tell you
from a very own experience it's not so
easy to have these NGS workflows and the
labs and there are some pain points
sometimes I really really look back to
these good old days where you just had a
very simple qPCR setup to for instance
query your expression levels of a
certain GE where you would just here on
the left here indicate on left hand side
purify your RNA sample and then do a
normalization do a cDNA to do this and
just the qPCR set up to query any gene
you would have been interested in also
me
NGS now makes it much much easier to
query all gene and one specific time
point meaning that is less biased
however the workflows also got much more
complicated so now starting of course
from the purified RNA I actually have to
follow this up to prepare my NGS
experiment by purifying the mRNA even
more the dua fragmentation synthesize
the first trend in the CDMA and then do
a second strands into this to another be
purification prepare an ATM in reaction
ligate my adapter then put it on my PCR
cycle or gain to do an application to
another bit purification quantify and
you see and then finally I can actually
start my NGS experiment so overall this
procedure takes a lot of my time in the
lab to get things going and it's not
only that
whenever I'm actually working with these
NGS samples
in a manual kind of way it really really
takes a lot of my attention because I
really have to sit there for two to
three days follow up to 140 steps in
this to seek stranded mrna protocol and
I'm always thinking what happens if
something goes wrong I spent $2,000 on
this entire kit and even more so if
something goes wrong these failures
quickly amounts for lost time and cost
so I'm really really sometimes wishing I
had things more standardized and more
easily available in the essay and I
don't only see this for this single
method but a lot of my peers they
actually coming to me and they telling
me like hey I need to sequence more
samples I need to have more
multi-layered data on those samples
because the cost is going down it's
going quicker and quicker and we also
want to have this data with a high
quality and on the other hand as we saw
on the first slide the sequencers the
chemistry they are becoming much more
readily available and in between the
supply and the demand in the middle
there is this tiny bottleneck which is
called the library prep where I need to
spend several days in the lab and that
that is a really really big pain point
for me so Tim do you maybe know what we
can do about that yeah mark are very not
so this is why I'm here basically
showing you the Eppendorf NGS solution
so we here at ethanol we have thought a
lot about all those pain points that you
have described and that not only your
experience but a lot of NGS customer out
there are experiencing and I also saw
a lot of the people in our audience are
experiencing the very same problem so
this is why we come up with a strategy
to make entry at library preparation
easier more more intuitive and also more
reproducible for the user
so in principle during the next couple
of minutes I would like to show you mark
what I would suggest you how to widen
this bottleneck how to overcome the
discrepancy between supply and demand
which has been the library preparation
and what we here at Eppendorf has is the
so called NGS library preparation
solution so we are not only offering a
single device telling you okay take this
device and then to figure out what you
want to do with it we are offering the
full solution for NGS library
preparation consisting of the entire
instrumentation and also high quality
low buying consumables all coming from
one manufacturer so the only thing
market you have to do is you have to add
your reagent you have to add your
samples and get started and if you think
that you would like to need some more
help from us here at Eppendorf from our
experts in the different countries or
from our headquarter
we also offer premium services to
support you both on-site and remote so
let's take a closer look at what we
think is the perfect solution for NGS
library preparation and I want to mainly
focus on the automation part which is
the EP motion so I'm coming from the
automation and this is why I will
emphasize a lot on the capability
of this great device so um the the two
devices that I want to present you here
are the et motion 5075 and it's smaller
sister DEP motion 50 73 so the EP motion
50 75 is our full-scale NGS library
automation system with with 14.5 dead
positions the great thing is that you
can still fit it on a bench top so it's
easy to set it up it doesn't need high
voltage and it fits into most standard
labs it is one system which does fit all
of your NGS needs the great thing is
that we do have a large number of
already qualified methods I will come to
that in a minute and it uses an
intuitive but yet very powerful software
which is both easy to operate but also
gives you as a user a lot of options
I will also dig a little bit deeper into
that as we take a look at the EP motion
5070 Frei 50 73 you can use it as a
small-scale NGS library automation
system for standalone use but it is also
a great companion for the easy motion
5075 so you could think about things
like splitting up your pre and post pcr
processes by using a EP motion 50 73
together with the et motion 50 75 the
easy motion 50 73 comes at a very
attractive price and it uses the same
powerful software as its larger sister
the EP motion 50 75 I was focused during
that talk on the AP motion 50 75 and I
will highlight a number of features the
system has and why those features are so
useful for NGS la
preparation so here you can see the
system as you see it's a fully enclosed
automated liquid handler with different
type of thing towards a gripper and the
integrated waste it is externally
operated by a touchscreen monitor system
so we do offer tools which are working
at an unrivaled high pipetting accuracy
and precision at the North has a long
history and building pipette and we have
taken that knowledge and put it into an
automated liquid handler so we have a
high precision and accuracy in a volume
range from 0.2 to 100 microliters in a
single type of thing steps we do have on
that thermal mixing which is great for
these tedious beat washing steps that
you have described mark so we can mix
beads on the system up with up to 2,000
rpm for a very homogeneous beat solution
we are very flexible in the number of
samples you use so with our new software
we can apply the automated tool exchange
which allows a quick change between
multi and single channel tools which
both it speeds up your process and it
gives you additionally more saundra
flexibility so every morning when you
step into your lab when you when you
start with your work you can decide how
many samples you want to run today
without having a big effort the software
is flexible and very easy to use and it
allows you also every day to adjust
single method steps if needed just
imagine one day you want to have longer
or shorter incubation times
can simply adjust those those steps with
a few clicks we have a touch free
detection of volumes which are used with
the system for example wash buffer and
we have a touch free scanning of the lab
where that you put on the deck which
both ensures safety and comfort so the
system always make sure before the run
that all the level is put in the right
position that all the left work is where
it should be
and that there are sufficient amounts of
liquids provided in order to fully
automate your process our system works
with contact free dispensing which means
that as opposed to a manual pipette the
liquid will not be transferred by
touching a vessel wall or by entering
another liquid it will be dispensed with
high velocity contact free which both
ensures perfect mixing of liquids
liquids and is a contamination free
system we have on deck heating and
cooling for the very important enzymatic
reactions during NGS library preparation
this drastically increases your work
away time and you can always be sure
mark that your samples are safe and
protective because the system is fully
housed and it comes with an optional
keep our clean air filter and UV
sterilization
the great thing about the you promotion
is that it is an open platform for
application automation so it is it is
comfortable with the Vice variety of NGS
library preparation workflows from
different distributors but it's not only
restricted to entry at library
preparation the system is also capable
of doing for example nucleic acid
preparation and also there we do support
kits from a lot of different
distributors it is the ideal supplement
to kouvaris in the true signal and
Agilent protocols because we cancel and
antico virus strips and it is it is the
perfect system for small and medium
scale labs without any experience and
automation whatsoever
because the system is easy to use it's
fast to set up and it has a very
intuitive software so I would say that
really everybody can use the EP motion
automatic liquid handler looking at
Angie has protocols so if I remember
back at my time where did my PhD my
professor always told me that if you
show a slide with a lot of different
things with long list with tables it's
basically to show off and yes I
apologize to my audience this slide is
to show off because I would like to
present you that at the EP motion has
the most luminaire qualified methods on
a single automated liquid handler so all
of the methods that you can see here on
the left hand side are officially
qualified by Illumina we do have a few
other methods work which are qualified
by our customers but we are not only
able to automate Illumina NGS library
preparation protocols we can also
automate
protocols of other reagent providers as
for example rocks or New England Biolabs
also here we are officially qualified
and customer qualified methods and if
you really stumble across a method that
we have not qualified or automated yet
you can always just contact us and ask
us if this method can be automated on
the EFT motion and in most of the cases
the answer will be yes we can do it so
you can be sure that you get your
customized method from us
okay but what are the general advantages
of lab automation and there are some
things that one want to consider which
are which not only apply for automatic
NGS library preparation but for lab
automation in general so first of all we
give you a system which is very
versatile so besides the NGS library
preparation you can automate your
everyday liquid handling steps like
cherry picking PCR set set up nucleic
acid purification but not only that it's
not restricted to simple liquid handling
or tasks which deal with nucleic acid
system can also be used at the cell
culture maintenance system or you can
automate your eliezer setup you can also
increase your throughput
the system is capable of running up to
96 samples per run depending on the
protocol so you can increase your
throughput without losing any accuracy
and precision in the in the packaging
and for me one of the most important
things is actually that an automated
liquid handler work error-free
so there's one thing mark and we have to
face it is that the major source of
piping errors in the lab it's not the
pipe itself it's not the tips it's not
the calibration it's mainly the pipe
abuser and I think we all know the
situation where you were setting up a
96-well plate for example you were
piping at position B 7 and then somebody
one of your peers comes in to the left
asks you a question you look up for a
second you look back at your plate and
you have no idea where you stopped you
have no idea whether you add your
reagents you have no idea whether you
already at your sample and in the worst
scenario this
can rip your whole experiment and this
is one of the biggest strengths of lab
optimation because the robot will not
forget the position it has been and the
robot the robot will not be interrupted
by one of your peers popping into the
room there's one thing I stumbled across
which I thought is kind of fascinating
is that in 2000 the average attention
span of a human was about 12 seconds now
with our smartphones and social media it
has dropped to about 8 seconds and the
average attention span of goldfish is 9
seconds so this is just to illustrate
you that even if you think that you are
like fully concentrated on the tasks you
can be very quickly distracted which can
cause an error and this is especially
with expensive envious library preps
where samples might be limited where we
agents are expensive this is definitely
something that you want to avoid of
course an automatic liquid handler
allows you to to track your sample all
along the process what happened to your
sample where did you start with where
did you end up with it does increase
your productivity because it frees your
time mark to to spend on more important
tasks than repetitive beat washing steps
so you can go you can you can read a
paper you can submit your next paper to
nature or science instead of doing beat
washing steps also an automated liquid
handler does offer you contamination
prevention so our EP motion is fully
enclosed if I have shown you it comes
with the HEPA filter and UV
sterilization if wanted we have
contamination free contact dispensing
our tools can be can be autoclaved and
we have high purity grades of our
consumables so and this ensures both
the safety of the user but most
important the safety of your precious
samples so one part of course is the
hardware it's what I have talked about a
lot during the last slide slides but
another very important part is the
software and in order not to show you
more slides about the software I thought
about sharing my screen and showing you
with the software life so I apologize
there might be a little bit of a delay
between me clicking on something and
something happening on the screen but I
will try my best to guide you through
our very intuitive software so since
this will really just be like a sneak
preview of the software I would
recommend you our previous webinar at
lab roots which is called intuitive and
easy programming of liquid handling
tasks with ep motion which can be found
at the lab roots home page as well as on
YouTube so if you really want to dive
deep into how easy it is to program
something with the EP motion just take a
look at this webinar and you can you can
learn a lot about leap ok so now I am
sharing my screen
so what you can see here is the EP blue
software which is our operating software
for the EP motion
so let's straight jump into one of our
qualified protocols in order to do that
I simply go to the application editor
then from the right-hand side I choose
my application which is NGS and hey Mark
I'm thinking about this protocol you
were telling me about the true side
stranded mRNA from Illumina which you
were struggling with right so let's
let's take a look at we do have this
protocol here so I go to Illumina and
also price the price I do have a folder
called through side stranded mRNA let's
take a look at it and yes we do have
qualified methods for this protocol and
the whole protocol is been subdivided
into three different parts as you can
see here so called sub methods and in
order to show you how those methods look
I will jump straight into one of those
sub methods which is method 2 so let me
get into this message okay now I'm
showing you this method and you can see
that this is how the software looks and
how displays the methods so on the right
hand side you can see a depiction of the
worktable which is basically the you can
imagine a depiction of your on your lab
space and on the left hand side you can
see the open application so here on the
work table you can see what you have to
put on the work table in order to get
the method running so you can see a lot
of tips that we need and you can see
number of PCR plays that will be used
our reagents and our adapters so let's
just assume that you want to change
something here it is actually very
simple and I will show you that so let's
say you want to put your tips not at the
tenth position but at another position
so you can simply drag and draw it move
with pause and back if you want to put
something else on the work table for
example a second waste reservoir just go
to to your left where that you want to
use here for example the top we take a
reservoir we drag and Robert we give it
a nice name let's call it wait - and
we're done so now we have put it on the
work table if you don't want to use it
you can just remove it okay so this is
the work table we have a second part
which is which are the so called
procedures so these are steps just like
in a protocol which are done
subsequently and as you can see here for
our true side strand and mRNA protocol
these are a number of steps which we
have pre-programmed for you but just
imagine that you want to change
something so for example you want to
change the temperature for the a tailing
you can simply click on on the step and
you can change the temperature to let's
say 36 degrees as easy as that
let me show you one other thing
so things that a lot of times get
changed is the pattern of the used
adapters so here we put a comment user
intervention
which tells you that you should review
steps 31 and 32 in order to adjust the
use of your adapters so let's do this we
can just scroll down to step 31 and 32
we can click on this liquid handling
step and we can change our pattern so
let's say I want to have my adapter in a
six go to go to a 1 and B 6 go to a 2
and so on and so forth alright so this
was really just a short glimpse on the
software if you want to learn more about
it I would really recommend your
previous webinar there I'm telling you
how easy it is to program your own
methods and how methods a bit up of
simple liquid transfer commands as well
as processes for example waiting and
mixing simple transport and interaction
commands with this I want to jump back
to our slides so I will
sharing the screen share and I will go
back to the slides so mark I hope at
this position I could give you an
insight about automation of NGS library
preparation and so what do you think
this is so awesome so that actually
means I can save myself
all of these trouble working in the lab
really really spending hours worrying
about everything and just forget about
it
do my data analysis and write my papers
and also I think you guessed this before
right you mentioned that this also works
with all the other f-bomb equipment I
already have in my lab so like this
really really really cool cycler I
purchased last year and which has a full
complete touch functionality and with
completely networked and I really love
this piece of equipment right it has
this really great list that prevents
this evaporation so I love it for my
long-range PCRs it has a very good
temperature homogeneity over the entire
block meaning I don't get these really
weird edge effects and I can really use
it to scale my application together with
Maya promotion because I don't only need
to use one cycler but I can couple them
actually in order to work together and
likewise also these really really cool
twin tech low band plays that I've been
using for years and my facility are
still really in that protocol so I can
really still make use of them I don't
have to adapt anything in there and I
really really have to say I'm very fond
of these consumable because they on the
one hand they have this very low
retention surface which is really
advantages with difficult samples and on
the other hand they are very rigid that
means they do not deform warp and then
mess up my experiments but actually do
have a very high performance build in
them and I believe you were also talking
about this really really cool
Eppendorf application notes where you
where I actually can see that for my
very sensitive are in a experiments I
can work with very low amount and still
get great results so that means I have
like a whole package that really really
rounds off that method and I think also
the last few weeks while I was telling
you about this manual issue that we're
having in the lab we really were also
running through the methods and you lose
the date and how it works so on overall
I really see that my advantage and also
probably a lot of our listeners here we
also see their advantage in that it
really transforms this really really
long workflow of three days into just
three simple sub methods where I at the
most we've all spent three days in the
lab actually during the library
preparation but just have something like
thirty minutes
hands-on time and then we'll run through
the protocols in eleven hours so I just
have to maybe interrupt the message when
I take stuff out of the cycler put it
back in but for the rest I can really
forget about it and we already saw
written in this practical way that this
actually read the look of great results
so I'm very very content that even at
the baseline of this protocol I was
working in with the the 100 nano chrome
which is at the lower end of what is
recommended to put in there I really got
great library without dimers and with
really really nice unbiased size
distributions and also the size
distributions were clustering very
tightly and I had a very nice feel
to actually start off my sequencing run
so that's that's really really really
awesome so I think it's not only one
thing right actually
when I go for the epi motion I can
actually get like an entire package yeah
that's true mark that's the one idea
behind it so the idea was to give you a
solution package to put things together
which provide you with everything that
you need except deviation so you just
have to add them in order to get started
right away so what we have as our NGS
solution package is our e t-- motion
5075 which has the built-in thermal
mixing module as well as an additional
thermal module for your enzymatic steps
which allows undec purification and and
intubation and increases your walkway
time drastically the system already
comes with all the tools needed so it
comes with the gripper to transport your
lobe and clay it comes with 50 micro
litre and 300 micro liter multi and
single channel tools which will cover
volume range from one microliter up to
three hundred microliters in a single
pipetting step and talking about
pipetting and low line plays this
package also includes our quality
automation tips as well as low lying
consumers to get you started right from
the beginning we will provide you with
our brand new it will be blue 40.6
software with which comes with enhanced
features so you have the full
flexibility you have our new
notification system you have a very
robust software to also modify your
processes we have improved
I will walk a bit walkway times and we
have further improved our flexibility by
the automated tool selection but still
even this is called NGS solution package
don't forget that you will you will get
a device which remains a general-purpose
machine which allows you to automate a
lot of different lab tasks that you do
every day if you are interested in it it
comes within the team cap version with a
HEPA clean air filter and UV
sterilization and don't worry about your
accessories because the system will have
all the accessories needed in order to
deal with semeth guarded plates micronic
tubes and your reagent tubes we do offer
a lot of qualified methods as I have
told you and they are available on the
on request so mark if you want to get
started and guys if you out there want
to get started the easiest way is to get
in contact with us to get in contact
with your local Eppendorf representative
so we have offices in most of the
countries out there we have a great
support and if you are in doubt please
feel free to all of the questions now
during the webinar we will answer all of
your questions you can also contact
automation - support at Eppendorf dot d
e if you come up with one question after
a good night of sleep and with that both
mark and me are at the end of our
presentation I hope that I could
convince you mark that
success can be automated for sure and I
hope our listeners as well thank you for
your attention
thank you we will walk up any questions
you have
thank you show marks and dr. Hahn for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now let's click
on the answer a question box located on
the far left of your screen well answer
as many of your questions we have time
for let's get started our first question
is for dr. Hahn dr. Hahn one of our
viewers States I am usually only
preparing a few samples out of time what
would be the benefit of using the EP
motion
oh thank you very much for that question
it's a really good question indeed
because my colleague dr. Shah mods
actually said at the beginning of this
presentation that with the AAP motion
you can scale up your production
capacity but it's really not only about
that because the Machine does less
errors and still features the
flexibility you would also need for
lower triples so definitely when you
would be considering doing a lower
number of samples for your library
preparation you could also still benefit
from the qualified methods plus it has
the added advantage that you do not
really need to Train anybody on the
method that's already pre-programmed but
you could actually already start using
that method the way it is without
getting into too much depth about the
protocol
thank you dr. Shah marks our next
question for you this states how do our
know when the team is finished
but sounds like a simple question but it
is actually a very good question so the
once the machine is finished and you are
close to the device you are in the same
room you can hear a beep and it will
show you a prompt where it has you
application success successfully
finished this is all good and sign but
in a lot of cases you will not be in the
same room as the device that's not the
idea of automation that you sit and
watch the device working so now with our
new software the 40.6 software which is
a brand new release we have implemented
a number of new comfort feature and
among them is the email notification
feature so it means that your EP motion
will send you an email to email address
of your choice telling you that an
application has finished but not only
that so this email notification can also
be used if for example in the middle of
the run you have programmed the step
where you want to provide very delicate
reagents may it be light-sensitive
reagents or something similar so it will
also send you a notification telling you
please add the requested reagent so that
you can sit on your dad you can do your
you can do your work and the device will
inform you when it needs any input and I
don't know if there are like any
listeners out there who are already
working with an EP motion and they might
ask themselves hey that's a great
feature but I don't have it yes that's
true because this is a feature which has
just been added with our new software
and along the email notification feature
there are a number of other new and
really exciting features for example the
automated tool selection as well as tip
box stacking and other thing
so if you are interested in that please
feel free to contact us anytime and we
can walk you to all of those things in
detail
thank you let's come back to you dr. Han
for the next question I have multiple
users in my lab can I only use the
system for NGS
oh that's also a really really good
question and of course in this webinar
we presented more or less our new NGS
solution package but that absolutely
does not mean that the system is limited
to next-generation sequencing actually
we do have a lot of customers and
methods when people have success we used
the EPI motion for PCR setup nucleic
acid purification with which was also
what you saw in this very brief moment
my colleague opened the software and the
different folders popped up so that
means also the system is very versatile
so as a capital equipment it would be
very easy to share among several users
and also it's the ease with which you
can modify and generate them simple
methods on the EPI motion actually makes
it very open to other users that want to
run different applications besides NGS
and besides this also of course you may
wish to have some kind of a user
management and the software will also
allow you to do that very effectively so
in case the question is aiming at this
part of the lab there's absolutely no
problem in generating several accounts
and having several layers so that
different users will be able to use the
software different levels
thank you Oh elves the question okay we
have time for one last question dr. shom
artists have you answer this one I have
never used automation before can I get
some special training
yeah also a very good question indeed
it's a question we do get a lot of time
because coming from manual liquid
handling this is at least what I've
experienced both with customers but also
myself that people are from time to time
a bit reluctant when it comes to
automation because they think ok this
must be like horribly complicated and I
need a degree in computer science or at
least some hacking skills in order to
operate the device and first of all I
hope that I could convince you during
this webinar that this is definitely not
the fact so the software is easy
drag-and-drop software so it's intuitive
it's simple to use it's simple to learn
and talking about learning the software
of course you are not alone with this so
if you want to play around and work it
out using the manual you can do so but
we offer qualified on-site trainings so
if you purchase an EP motion it it does
come with an initial training of the
software where you learn all the basic
features how you program the EP motion
how you operate it
we do offer another service which i
think is absolutely great so we call it
application implementation and this is
really a customized service which is
tailor-made depending on the process
that you are doing so for example if you
do NGS library preparation one of our
automation specialists will come to your
lab and we will have an in-depth look at
the application that you are running and
we will write a customized protocol for
that very application where we introduce
all of the steps that you want to
introduce where we adjust all of the
timings all of the left where according
to your needs
this can also offer as some sort of
automation consulting so if you have a
given workflow and you are not 100% sure
whether it can be automated or not you
can you can contact us and we can do we
can do the job so we can automate it for
you we can get it to run on your EP
motion I'm not sure if this is where
this question was aiming for but I hope
I answered it as good as possible
thank you again dr. Shawn Mars and dr.
Han we are just about out of time
do either of you have any final comments
for our audience
want to thank all of the listeners for
tuning in and I hope we have sparked
your interest into the AP motion and in
our Eppendorf NGS solution and whenever
you have any questions even after the
webinar again as my colleague mentioned
please feel free to tune in and just
send us an email and we will be there
and get back to you although for those
questions we could announce in our case
the time was too short and it's really
nothing much that I can add I totally
agree to my colleague thanks for tuning
and have a wonderful day and we hope to
hear from you very soon
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor at the
door for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through October 2018
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that with your email your
in your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye